I'm delighted to be here to see you all
on such a beautiful day not outside in
the sunshine so I'm going to talk about
tools for thinking one of my students
famously said or I love it you can't do
much carpentry with your bare hands you
can't do much thinking with your bare
brain oh by the way can I have the house
lights up I really like to see faces
this isn't a drama thank you I'll try to
make it entertaining but it's not you
know thank you
how many do you know about the Flynn
effect oh only a few okay named after
Jim Flynn James Flynn psychologist he
didn't do the original research but he's
drawn attention to the importance of it
it turns out that since the in the
hundred years that we've had IQ tests
scores have been going up IQ tests are
normalized at a hundred being the
average and that so you have to keep
tweaking that scoring system but if you
give the tests that you gave in 1932
people today they'll score on average a
hundred and thirty not a hundred at
least as the whole world over to it's
not it's not just in any one area at
least we're a lot better at taking IQ
tests than we were 8090 years ago but it
seems to be a real pattern and what's
what might cause that Flynn thinks that
what's happened is that the tools for
thinking that are developed and proved
and and refined in in the sciences and
then the other academic disciplines have
sort of filtered down into popular
culture and become part of the ambient
culture that you learn independently of
school and that this is why people are
actually thinking better they're
actually better problem solvers they see
patterns better and so forth in any case
it's a hypothesis that hasn't been
disproven and it has a good chance of
being the right the right answer to that
question and the reason I mention it is
because if you ask me wait a minute are
you saying that these thinking tools
actually make us smarter I'm saying yes
yes they do so what are some thinking
tools well par excellence the thinking
tools or words can't do much thinking
without words and I'm reminded of a
famous line of Goethe's when ideas fail
words come in very handy he really
didn't say that and when you think about
it you realize what wisdom is there when
the when the thinking gets really hard
you can often use words as a certain
sort of prosthetic device a crutch to
help you over some difficult stretches
numbers obviously our thinking tools
diagrams Maps methods of all kinds from
finding the average the long division to
cost-benefit analysis you name it notice
that these are all quite abstract things
they're they're techniques for handling
information in your head rather than
tools that you plug in or need a power
source for then there's intuition pumps
I coined the term way back in 1980 or 81
in order to talk about John Searles
famous or notorious Chinese room thought
paramount I said it's an intuition pump
and because I was on that occasion
criticizing a lot of people thought that
I meant the term intuition pump
pejoratively no I didn't actually and
I've since explained that I think
intuition pumps at their best are
wonderful they are the best
philosophical thinking tools there are
and they always have been if you look at
the history of philosophy Plato's cave
of Socrates teaching the slave boy
geometry they carts evil demon Hobbes
state of nature these are the these are
the great melodies of philosophy that
you remember long after you forgotten
the details of the arguments so
philosophers have always used intuition
pumps little stories scenarios vignettes
and they're not typically formal
arguments they're little stories it's
not like doing songs when you get to the
end you've got the answer
very few intuition pumps are like that
they're much more like Aesop's fables
you get the end there's a little moral
you hmm
interesting you'd put it that way and if
it really works you pound your fist on
the table so it's got to be that way
that's the intuition that's been pumped
now there are persuaders in other words
somebody wrote me the other day saying
well I've looked at your book now and I
think what you're really talking about
in every case you're talking about
social thinking you're talking about
persuading others it's it's very much
interpersonal and I wrote back said yes
and in fact I should have stressed that
more all really serious thinking is
interpersonal I think I think that's in
fact one of the keys to how we think is
by challenging each other with our ideas
lovely case in point
Andrew Wiles proved Fermat's Last
Theorem a few years back but nobody
could be sure even Wiles himself
couldn't be sure he'd done it until his
peers his colleagues in mathematics who
would dearly love to have the honor of
having proved Fermat's Last Theorem
themselves until they had signed off and
said darn it yes he's got it
congratulations
this competitive opponent process
between people is actually one of the
key intuition pumps are the key thinking
tools all on its own and so this is a
book very much about how to persuade
others and yourself about difficult
matters there are also tools of
discovery by exploring these vignettes
you uncut you encounter either problems
that you hadn't anticipated or sometimes
opportunities that you would not
otherwise notice and they hold our
attention you you can just refer back to
them and at least they give you a focus
on a topic that's very useful now some
fields of academic inquiry have lots of
fixed points just in moveable bedrock
philosophy I think has none hardly a one
maybe the law of non-contradiction
according to Aristotle what we have are
candidates for fixed points we say in
effect suppose for the sake of argument
we treat this and this and this at six
points now what follows from those three
points triangulate those see what kind
of a theory you can make of that see how
the questions look if we take those as
fixed points so very often an intuition
pump is a is a wonderful fixer of a
candidate for a fixed point and that's a
very valuable tool in itself how
powerful are these tools they're this
powerful they drove what is one of the
great biological phenomena in the
history of life on this planet
Paul MacCready the late great green
engineer if you don't know who Paul
MacCready is I'll probably be able to
identify it for you by drawing attention
the fact that he's the one who designed
and built the gulfs of gossamer
albatross
the human powered airplane that flew
across the British Channel he pointed
out that at 10,000 years ago a twinkling
engine in biological time at the very
dawn of Agriculture our species plus its
livestock and its pets was a fraction of
one percent of the by weight if you like
of the terrestrial vertebrate biomass a
minor primate
what is it today ten thousand years
later any guesses 99 percent eighty five
out here any others you know that's not
true there are a few bears out in the
woods but it's actually it's 98 percent
most of that's cattle but in ten
thousand years our species plus its
domesticated animals have completely
transformed the biosphere in a way that
really hardly I don't think any earlier
global event can compete with that for
the changes that have been wrought in
just ten thousand years and this is what
this is what McCready says about it over
billions of years on a unique sphere
chance is painted a thin covering of
life I love that image chance has
painted a thin covering of life complex
improbable wonderful and fragile
suddenly we humans have grown in
population technology and intelligence
to a position of terrible power we now
wield the paintbrush that's true
and we have the same genes that our
ancestors 10,000 years ago had they're
our ancestors a hundred thousand years
ago pretty much it's not genetic it's
thinking tools that have made this all
puff possible which raises a chicken-egg
problem did evolve tools make us smarter
or did we evolve to become smart enough
to make tools and the answer as to all
good chicken-egg problems is yes it's
co-evolutionary it's a sort of
bootstrapping thing where we get a
little bit smarter smart enough to make
a few tools and then those tools make a
smarter still and so it goes building
and building and building my next book
is going to be about that process so
some simple tools from the book
everybody knows reductio ad absurdum
even if you don't know the name it is
that you might say it's the great
crowbar of thought it is the way you
budge people from their position by
taking their premises saying well if we
assume for the sake of argument that
your premises are such-and-such look
what I can do and then you deduce
logically from those premises a
contradiction something absurd in fact
we use this all the time in more more
informally and don't even notice it but
it's really the same thing I mean if you
say if that's a bear then bears have
antlers that's really a sort of reductio
ad absurdum argument I mentioned it in
part because I want to point out that
although we use reductio ad absurdum
arguments in either expanded or
truncated form we also imply them all
the time using rhetorical questions a
rhetorical question whenever you see one
one of those questions it isn't supposed
to be answered stop and think about it
it's an implied reductio the idea is
haha you can't answer this question it
would be
it's it's so obvious that that the
answer to this question is so obvious
that I don't even have to mention what
the answer is everybody knows that's
nudge well that means that a good
practice a habit to get into is when you
see one of those question marks in a doc
document a rhetorical question try
answering the question and see if maybe
it's not so ridiculous after all
in one of my favorite peanuts cartoon
strips Charlie Brown says something like
well who's to say what is right and what
is wrong and Lucy says I will and try it
you'll like it sometimes you can really
bring a person up short by just
answering their their rhetorical
question then there's the Shirley alarm
I tell my students every time you see
the word Shirley a little bell should
ring ding and you should pause hearing
the Shirley alarm and you should look to
see if you have just found the weak
point in the argument why well
what follows the Shirley is a sentence
that the author wants you to believe is
putting forward is true it's not so
obvious that it goes without saying if
it were it would go without saying and
here the author is putting it in but not
bothering to argue for us instead trying
to get by on the cheap with a little
nudge a little Shirley so if you have a
Shirley alarm and this becomes just a
habit in your mind this this will stand
you in good stead I've been inviting
people to send me now that they've
installed a Shirley alarm in their brain
to tell send the examples where they
catch the catch of Shirley marking a
weak spot I did a little research on
this I actually went
and string search for surely in several
dozen actually more like 70 or 75
philosophy papers online and found a
couple of dozen Shirley's and check them
out and and about a third of them work I
thought clearly the weakest point in the
case being made in that in that article
it doesn't work all the time and a lot
of false alarms you can go ahead and use
the word shortly every now and then but
if you hear the word surely you should
ding so we just give it a little try
because surely if you I didn't hear it
if surely if you get in the habit of
whenever you hear the word surely a
little bell rings practice surely being
thank you now look what I've done I've
just downloaded and apt to your neck top
in the same way that an app on your on
your smartphone adds to the
functionality it gives gives your
smartphone a new talent a new capacity
it's like Google Alert or something like
that you now have another little tool in
your kit that may very well alert you to
a weak spot in some argument through
your otherwise impressed with okay
computers are of course thinking tools
par excellence and I there's a lot about
computers in the book and I have learned
from many years experience that a lot of
people think they understand how
computers work and they don't really and
if they just understood a bit more they
would understand a lot more things that
can be easily understood with the help
of computers so there's there's an
interlude on computers including what
must be an eccentric first in a trade
book there's actually a chapter which
teaches you how to program the world's
simplest computer a register machine and
there are even problem sets with the
answers at the back of the book if you
will spend a couple hours with that
chapter you will understand computers
the way you never understood them before
but of course you're free to pass over
that if you really don't care how long
by the way was a philosopher who came up
with the idea of a register machine
around the same time little after
girdle's famous proof and touring coming
up of the Turing machine and the the
long register machine this is is
computes everything that storing
computable so it's a it's a
user-friendly alternative to a Turing
machine if you've ever tried to program
a touring machine you know it's hard
it's very counterintuitive but a
register machine is very easy to
understand it's it's the world's
simplest computer and
are some little exercises on that now
here's some thinking tools
well actually this picture I want to
point out this is a this picture is all
by itself for thinking too it draws
attention to a rather striking
comparison and provokes reflection the
one on the left is in a chalet and
hand-axe the one on the right I don't
need to tell you notice the actual hand
axe was used in this form unchanged
without any noticeable improvements for
over a million years weird really
strange the mouse in comparison has only
been around for a few decades and is
probably on the way out the speed of
tool use and improvement is picked up a
little bit over biological time here's
another thinking tool all on its own the
comparison between these two entities on
the left you see an Australian termite
castle on the right you see gaudi's
famous Church in Barcelona the Sagrada
família they're strikingly similar in
appearance and actually in structure
even internally they're quite remarkably
similar
so here are two artifacts made by
animals looking very similar and yet
profoundly different in both the design
and construction the one on the left is
designed by Darwinian processes clueless
mindless little termites it's all local
action there's no there's no blueprint
there's no intelligent designer there's
no no boss there's no hierarchy it's
bottom-up construction in sort of every
sense of the word
whereas Gaudi is the very model of an
intelligent designer autocratic full of
manifestos and blueprints and orders
ordering the underlings around now
they're both natural and one of the
really interesting questions is how do
we get in this on this planet how did we
get from termites tile design and
construction to gaudí's style design
construction how did the second kind
evolved from the first that's a very
deep and interesting question that's the
one that I am now devoting as much time
as I can to and will attack in the next
book and I hope I'll be back to talk
about that one more visual thinking tool
is this my favorite picture of the Tree
of Life this is Leonard Eisenberg's and
you can you can get this as a big
beautiful glossy poster to put up on
your on your wall in your study or in
your classroom or you can get t-shirts
and buttons and all sorts of things
what's really nice about it is that so
many features that are important to
understand or rendered so vivid here's
the birth of the earth and time this is
four billion years ago and here's the
present out around the outside edge so
this represents all living things today
and this represents where it started and
we see that the bacteria in the archaea
came first then we had this amazing
event the the eukaryotic revolution when
an endosymbiotic event joined to
prokaryotes to simple cells into a
symbiotic Union and that was the first
eukaryotic cell and everything else
these are all eukaryotes to a first
approximation every living thing that's
big enough to see you the naked eye is a
eukaryotic
including you and me and oak trees and
fish and all the rest you can see some
important events here's the Cambrian
explosion 530 million years ago when
was this sudden influx of many different
life forms new body plans new ways of
making a living Steve Gould famously
wrote about that tremendous creative
period and way over here that little
that little fork right there that's
about seven billion years just from that
crotch right there seven million years
fuse me that's about the length of time
that we has passed since we shared a
common ancestor with the chimpanzee and
of course language and culture is just
right out here right out here so in in
in just what's happened just in the last
fine fringe is everything that's
transformed the world thanks to thinking
tools and notice it on this whole Tree
of Life the termites are on there the
the birds building their nests are on
there the first intelligent designers
show up on one twig in very recent times
in the last hundred thousand years or so
and becoming more intelligent as they go
now give you a few examples of intuition
pumps just because of so far I've just
been talking about simple tools here's
the nefarious neurosurgeon first a
little science fact da me and Denise in
Amsterdam has developed a little
microchip that can be surgically
implanted in your head if you suffer
from obsessive-compulsive disorder it
will control your obsessive compulsive
disorder quite well it's it's being
implanted in a lot of people today and
so far the results are good its
experimental but very promising
that's fact now fiction so you see one
day this fellow who has OCD goes to see
his neurosurgeon and asks her to implant
the Denis chip and she does and as she's
sewing him up and shaking his hand and
sending him out of her shiny surgery she
says oh yes your
OCD is a thing of the past it would be
completely controlled by the chip and by
the way our staff here will be
monitoring you 24/7 and electronically
we will be controlling all your
decisions from now on you will have the
illusion of free will but it's just an
illusion thank you have a nice life says
about the door he believes her well
shiny lab white lab coat neurosurgeon
and believing her he begins to act a
little bit irresponsibly he's a little
self-indulgent indulging his worst whims
becomes a little arrogant a little
aggressive and before long he gets in
trouble with the law
and he says to the judge but your honor
I don't have any free will the
neurosurgeon told me I don't have any
free will you can't hold me responsible
they call the neurosurgeon to testify
and she says under oath yeah I'm I told
him all right I was I was just messing
with his head you know I never thought
he'd believe me now I think we can all
agree can we not here's the intuition I
want to pump she did an awful thing that
was that was a really bad thing she did
to him she actually accomplished with
her words what she claimed to accomplish
surgically electronically she disabled
him as a free agent now if I've secured
that intuition then I can go on and say
to the neuroscientists of its design for
and so tell me exactly how is it that
your own recent pronouncements in many
books and popular articles the nurse
science shows that there is no free will
that free will is an illusion and I've
got quotes - exactly that effect from a
lot of very eminent people I say why
isn't that just doing wholesale what she
did retail why isn't that a really
dangerous and irresponsible thing to do
to a person to suggest that their free
will is an illusion now this of course
raises some questions about well
what's the difference between what
they're saying and what she said there
are differences and they're important
differences but in the meantime we have
a lot of cognitive scientists and
neuroscientists and philosophers going
around saying neuroscience shows that
nobody has free will
nonsense it shows no such thing and it's
very important that we stop that
bandwagon before it builds up a head of
steam or it will start doing some real
damage there is by the way empirical
evidence that people who have been told
this message become more irresponsible
vos and schooler Jonathan schooler out
at the University of California Santa
Barbara did a very clever experiment
where they had subject undergraduate
students as usual but in two groups one
group was given a passage from Francis
Crick's book the astonishing hypothesis
Oh which talked about consciousness the
other group was given another passage
from the same book by Nobel laureate
Francis Crick which says free will is an
illusion both groups of students are
then given a test or it's a puzzle to
solve and they're going to get paid for
how well they do in the puzzle and
deliberately the experimenters have made
it possible to cheat on this test and
the students who saw who read the
passage where Crick says that they don't
have any free will they cheated
significantly more than the students who
read the other passage and that study
has been replicated so this is a this is
a real this is not just a fantasy of
philosophers but now you think what
still doesn't don't we learn from brain
science that since brains are more or
less determined and what's going on and
then probably doesn't owe anything to
quantum effects in the brain doesn't
that show we don't have free will it
well let's see I want to
ask you whether you think the fall which
of the two lotteries are fair in lottery
a the winning ticket is chosen after the
tickets are sold that's most lotteries
are like that you buy a ticket then they
make have a ceremony where they choose
the winning ticket lottery B is just the
same except the winning ticket is chosen
before the tickets are sold and the
ticket stub is locked away in a vault
until after the tickets are sold now how
many of you think that lottery B is
unfair that that you don't really have a
chance of winning lottery B that lottery
a may be fair but lottery B is is just
some kind of a hoax how many of you
think that hardly anybody I think I
think the audience is right they are
eeeek there's they're equally good both
of them both of you have no and after
all Publishers Clearing House bets on
this they sent you send out those
envelopes you may already have one you
know a million dollars or whatever
people see that both of these are fair
lotteries with opportunities to win in
both cases but now look if determinism
is true then you're all your lottery
tickets were chosen before you were born
and put in an envelope for you to use as
you needed a coin flip as you needed a
little bit of luck right so what people
say well you know then you're determined
to have good luck on some occasions and
had luck on others yeah but that's true
even if in determinism is true there's
no difference between in determinism and
determinism as far as you're having
opportunities in this life so we should
temper our conviction very traditional
conviction that there's a deep
incompatibility between determinism and
free will and moral responsibility it
just isn't there it takes a lot of
intuition pumps to get people to see
that but
is one okay the philosopher David
Wiggins once said many years ago talking
about this issue you talked about the
cosmic unfairness of determinism and I
think a lot of you say yeah I know what
he means yeah
cosmic unfairness of determinism yeah
well what about the cosmic unfairness of
in determinism they are equal on this
score you're going to win some you're
going to lose some the luck average is
out in most cases not perfectly that's
life you can't get around that in
determinism doesn't give you any more
luck
any more opportunities any more free
will anymore elbowroom
than you would have in a deterministic
world I dare say I haven't persuaded
many of you of that but give me time I'm
working on it okay so there they are the
book is sort of like at APIs in a 77
thinking tools 77 little chapters and
the point of the term intuition pump is
that you're encouraged to think of these
as gadgets as devices you should take
them apart see how they work
reverse-engineer them turn all the knobs
see why they do what they do then you
can build your own thanks for coming
so now questions we have microphones yes
um earlier on you mentioned Chinese room
scenario as a thinking pump that's like
a sort of bass one I was wondering if
you go into more detail about that haha
I'm going to decline for it but I'm
going to explain why I'm going to
decline John Searles chinese room has
been amazingly successful as a persuader
for now over 30 years and I have spent
many hours every year in the last 30
trying to explain to people why it is
not a good intuition pump
why it is defective and I've learned
several things from this one of them is
that if you don't understand how
computers really do their work you don't
get it
Searle is rudely dismissive of what he
calls the system's reply but anybody who
understands computers knows that the
system reply is just obviously right so
you have to you have to take you have to
read the chapter you have to become
computer literate in this rather strong
way to understand why Searles thought
experiment is defective in fact I teach
my students at Tufts how to program
register machines in my regular
undergraduate course on language in mind
this is I say this is just a thinking
tool that you should have later in the
course end of the course they get to
read Searle and they all see right
through it but it would take me too long
to lead you through all those exercises
that's why you have to buy the book
but I want to add something to that too
I notice what I try to explain this to a
lot of people girls what's wrong with
girl their eyes glaze over and I realize
that if I prod them a little bit I know
why they hate the idea that artificial
intelligence is possible they love the
fact that a Berkeley professor has an
argument which has as its conclusion
that strong AI is impossible and that
suits them just fine they don't want to
hear the details they like the
conclusion don't bother me with the
details it looks to them like nitpicking
well I used to hold that attitude in
contempt I thought this was this is the
worst sort of anti intellectual attitude
and then I caught myself doing it on a
related issue or know a different issue
I will confess that I find the
Copenhagen interpretation of quantum
mechanics ugly offensive I just don't
want it to be true and I don't want it
to be accepted and I know a lot of
people share that attitude with me but
never mind that's not the point
my what I've always felt oppressed by
the Copenhagen interpretation and
thought gosh I hope I just don't want
that to be right and then Murray
gell-mann Nobel laureate in physics in
his book the quark and the Jaguar takes
off after the Copenhagen interpretation
and he just beats the tar out of it he
is just hit em again Murray and the
chapter called Quantum flapdoodle he
no-holds-barred he just lets the quantum
interpretation have it between
right both barrels right between the
eyes and I found myself reading that
proof
hit him again Mary I love this I love
this and then I realized I'm not
qualified to judge Murray gell-mann
argument maybe I'm just being taken in
by the rhetoric and the fact that he's
got a Nobel Prize I'm so pleased that
there's a Nobel laureate who's on my
side and that's the way people feel a
lot of them about Searle that's why it's
an uphill battle a lot of people want
Searle to be right they are offended by
the idea of artificial intelligence and
they don't want to listen to some
nitpicker who says the argument doesn't
work so I've come to temper my view I
realize that there can be deep aesthetic
and emotional antipathies to a certain
view which can get in the way of a
patient consideration of the arguments
so you see I've mellowed
but I've also explained to you at great
length why I'm not going to talk about
the Chinese rule I profess it in it and
I come up here okay upstairs upstairs
hello and I agree with you about the
systems reply so I suppose they need to
buy the book or anything and do you
think that the the logical endpoint of
our thinking tools is the what some
people call whole brain emulation of the
uploading of the human mind to an
artificial system where we can have
tools far beyond our current imagining
do you think it's possible I think it's
possible in principle very unlikely in
fact there's lots of things that are
possible in principle that would be
nevertheless technologically unrealistic
my favorite example is would it be
possible to build a robotic bird that
could perch on a twig and catch insects
on the fly and way you know a few
hundred grams
yeah possible in principle don't expect
it I say that knowing that some of my
robotics friends are developing little
robotic insects with cameras on them
that can sort of be the fly on the wall
so we're getting closer but still I
think the sort of adroitness of an
insect averse bird will probably evade
technology indefinitely and there's no
real reason to do it and I think the
same thing is true about sort of whole
brain emulation you've got I've recently
by the way sort of changed my mind about
about the brain as a computer as I told
I said in your neck top I do think your
brain is a computer it's not at all like
your laptop well it is it is because
it's a computer but the organization and
the construction of the cerebral
computer has some fundamental
differences from any device that we've
built so far out of silicon for one
thing in a computer every memory place
every flip flop every logic it they're
all exactly alike write down practically
to the atoms and the reliability of the
system depends on that tremendous
uniformity it's a it's a masterpiece of
precision engineering your brain has
somewhere between say 100 and 200
billion neurons no two are alike and
they have their own agendas they're not
as slavish as the flip flops in the
machine
they are computing there are a whole
bunch of slightly willful selfish
interacting slaves and they do can
cute but not really the way your laptop
computes so I think the task of
emulating all of that in silicon is
possible in principle but really
unlikely after all not only do you have
some hundreds of billions of neurons
you've got ten times more astrocytes
glial cells in your brain and although
we used to think of them as sort of
little pillows that just protected the
neurons no no no turns out they're
computing - so the brain we now realize
is orders of magnitude more complicated
than we thought just a few years ago so
don't hold your breath thanks who's that
the mic okay here and then there
go ahead given the natural and acquired
deficiencies and limitations for minds
where do you see the greatest dangers in
the way we make decisions and what is
the change or what are the changes that
need to happen
oh that's very good and because it
permits me to to illustrate one of my
main themes many of the thinking tools
that we've developed over the centuries
have been designed as prosthetic
improvements on our natural equipment
which is really faulty as we've
discovered we're lousy for instance of
probability naturally we're as George
Angley points out we are exponential
discounters of future events and that's
just wrong it's a fallacy but Nature has
built us that way we have lots of
foibles little cognitive glitches and a
lot of people who pointed them out in
recent years Danny Kahneman and Amos
Tversky in a famous series of papers and
now more recently Danny's got the book
out on Thinking Fast and Slow
but the point is that we can think slow
and when we think slow using words tools
and using the methods that we've devised
we can overcome the natural limitations
of our brains and we can become to put
it bluntly more civilized and more
rational and the vert crack that you
asked the question in a little recursive
loop shows that we can be indefinitely
self-critical and critical of what we're
doing so far as as we discover problems
in collective irrationality we can start
devising solutions or workarounds for
those problems I think we can I don't
see any thing like you know a sound
barrier or a brick wall that will
prevent us from continuing to transcend
our current cognitive limits with
further limits I don't see any any
natural stopping point to that I'm sure
there will always be things we'll never
understand but that doesn't impress me
because never is a long way away
and the things that matter to us I see
no reason why we can't understand them
now where somebody on yeah yeah maybe
here okay good yeah I struggled with
your talk I was intrigued by the problem
you sat at the beginning which said that
IQ has increased and I struggled because
what I heard afterwards was a long list
of thinking tools but what I didn't hear
was statistical or measurable analysis
of what caused that change or how it
could be demonstrated last week there
was an article in The Times newspaper
that said that thinking speeds have
decreased significantly since the
Victorian times thinking skills speeds
average thinking speeds have disagreed
feeds young
that the speed people take to come to a
certain decision or work something out
has actually slowed down another example
in the UK some people might not agree
with me but many people think that
educational standards particularly at
secondary school have been dumbed down
significantly universities certainly
complain about that a lot and so
wouldn't one see actually a decrease in
IQ in certain advanced countries because
of that so can you give any examples of
how people have statistically or
scientifically measured and what
actually increases IQ what decreases it
yeah Jim Flynn and many others have done
a lot of statistical research and have
explored various hypotheses and it's not
diet and it's not wealth and it's
worldwide and the results seem to be
quite robust and culture independent and
I mean I can't I can't cite chapter and
verse I except to say just just google
it and thinking of talking about
thinking to Google James Flynn and the
Flynn effect and you will find a feast
of online materials to peruse now I I'm
interested in this Times reported study
of slowed down thinking and I I want to
see what's involved one possibility of
course is that by slowing down people
are thinking better of just taking a
little more time because their tools
take a little more time to work after
all one of the messages of Danny
Kahneman's book Thinking Fast and Slow
is there are things that Thinking Fast
is good at and then there are things
that you better think slow or you won't
get it right and it might be that we've
shifted the balance since Victorian days
whether whether this is a part of the
increase in general capacity to not make
mistakes or whether it's a decrease I
don't know but it's an interesting
question it might well be that it pays
to slow down on some of these tasks and
that's something we've learned
I'll look into that yes I'm sorry this
is moving too far away okay yeah there
you go okay
moving too far away from topic but I'm
really interested to you to you here
what do you think victim Stein would
make of the four horsemen of atheism
well I don't know I'm happy to answer
the question now lo I don't think when I
was a student I was a very great
appreciator of the later Wittgenstein
along with my fellow Oxford students
although I did not think of him as the
sort of intellectual Saint that they did
and in fact I found a lot of Vidkun
Stein's later work to be suspiciously
mysterious and I I fled that it's
interesting you know he had some
training as an engineer and I've met
other engineers who at a certain point
in their life suddenly take a swan dive
into philosophy and it's usually
disastrous Viktor Stein clearly wasn't
that kind of thinker he was I think
himself a great constructor of intuition
pumps what he would make of the of the
Four Horsemen of atheism I I have no
idea I would expect probably he would
have a mixed reaction but I won't try to
untangle it thank you
yeah this is a non sequitur so feel free
not to answer but I'm could you think of
an intuitive way to explain to a
colorblind person that there's
information the visual spectrum that
they're missing out on as a person who's
not color blind oh sure I think in fact
my experience with people who are
colorblind is that they understand color
fully well they can't pass the Ishihara
tests but they know what what it's like
to pass the test as well as something
after all I think I can explain to you
what it's like to be a pigeon who's a
Tetra Chrome instead of a tri-chromatic
vision and and and and they see more
colors than we do and things that you
and I would find indistinguishable in
color are sharply different to them and
I we can go into the details I don't
think this I don't think it's impossible
to do the hard work of imagining what
this is like in detail hello hello there
we are okay the lights are down so low I
can't really see back there I we've been
thinking about intuitive tools and I
just wondered whether you think that
women are more intuitive than men as
they often think they are
oh you're trying to lead me into waters
where I do not want to go but actually
I'm glad you asked me the question
because by intuition pump I sort of
don't mean that everyday sense of
intuition I'm talking about intuition
and the philosopher sense of something
that occurs to you that you just think
has got to be right and you're not quite
sure why I mean it happens all the time
I remember actually the first pop paper
I ever published was about artificial
intelligence and Hubert Dreyfus had
written his famous alchemy and
artificial intelligence diatribe against
AI years before Searle and in that piece
Dreyfus said that they'd never make a
computer with intuition that no computer
program would ever have intuition and in
my first publication I said actually
it's child's play to make a computer
that has intuition you take your
computer program that solves any problem
you like it might be long division or
weather prediction or whatever and you
ask it a question it gives an answer and
you say how did you work out that answer
and it says I don't know it just came to
me
intuition is when you've got a
conviction you haven't the faintest idea
how you got it when you have an
intuition pump you and you know that
before the intuition pump you didn't
have the idea now you do you can be
pretty sure that the causation runs
through that pump somehow now you take
the pump apart see how it works and you
get insight into how you arrived at that
intuition and I'm not going to touch the
rest of that way yes in the same way
that we're not quite as good with axes
as some of our forebears do you think
that generations get better and worse as
using thinking tools and if so where do
you see the future well first of all
let's let's confirm that people get
worse how many in this room know how to
run a slide rule is there anybody under
40 who knows how to run a slide rule or
how many of you can actually do the
algorithm for finding a square root yeah
but not many use it or lose it
when you can do it all on your hand
calculator you don't bother learning the
technique anymore and you know GPS is
probably seriously diminishing our
capacity to read maps wonderful thinking
tool which is you know becoming more and
more sort of obsolete and so forth so I
think that with the times different
tools play roles of greater or lesser
importance in what we're doing that will
no doubt continue and the user to lose
it
maksim will I daresay be maintained in
full force I've always admired and
envied my British colleagues who were
required in their youth to memorize lots
of poetry and I love it I love the way
they can just find the right line from
Shakespeare play or a poem and I wish I
could do that
I can't of course if I really want to
get that line I can I can get on the web
and usually find something appropriate
pretty fast but it's not the same talent
they have but after all nobody today
bothers to memorize train timetables but
people used to do that as a sort of
intellectual exercise I would think we
would find better ways of being
intellectual athletes then then that and
our new tools permit us to do that so I
think we'll go on I think Andy Clark
wonderful philosopher of cognitive
science and Edinburgh puts it very well
when he says that we we we make smart
tools to take the load off our brain so
that we can we can be stupid and still
be sort of smart uh-huh thanks to the
help we get from our tools and I think
that's years ago actually let me let me
expand on that a little bit more years
ago at tufts george smith my wonderful
colleague and i created something called
the curricular software studio and this
was to bring computers to bear on the
toughest thinking problems we knew this
was creating what what we called
prosthetics of the imagination and one
of them was it was a simulated computer
on a computer a 12 bit computer with 256
registers and but you could watch the
instruction cycle happen you could you
could completely see slowed down about a
million fold and enlarge about a million
fold what was going on inside the very
box that it was simulated on that was a
lovely thinking tool for
or expanding people's imagination giving
them a really vivid and reliable robust
tool for imagining things with computers
then we did the same thing for
population genetics and we had a program
called gene right after Sewell right
which had this these wonderful
simulations of population genetics and
you could you could sort of see at a
glance
once you use how to learn how to use
that tool what was the recessive
characteristic and why and so forth and
it was good enough tools so that the the
evolutionary biologists who helped us
create it would use it in her own
research to test her hunches before she
went to the trouble of seriously
modeling them and we did other we called
them concept pianos the reason we called
them concept pianos was that in my
eagerness to find other fields where we
could apply this I talked to a dear
friend of mine in the music department
who taught harmony courses and said
could we could we make a software device
that would help you teach students
harmony theory and we sat down and
brainstormed for a couple of hours and
realized that what we just invented was
the piano
it's wonderful you get the auditory and
you get two different visualizations you
get the keyboard and then you've got the
music in front of you it's it's very
user friendly you can get it running
right away but it's indefinitely
expandable there's really no better
instrument for learning harmony theory
than a piano we couldn't really improve
on it so we but we were making concept
pianos and other areas and the way we
used to sort of sell the idea to funders
and people like that they'd say look
there's two ways that technology can
make you smart the same way there's two
ways that technology can make you strong
there's the bulldozer way you're still a
98-pound weakling but in your bulldozer
you can move mountains and then there's
the Nautilus machine way you use the
technology to actually improve your
muscles in your coordination and so
forth and we said what we're trying to
do here is make the Nautilus machines of
the technology so that they actually you
walk away with something in your head
that makes you smarter by expanding by
giving you these imagination tools
I think that's we don't want to lose
sight of the fact that we can use
technology that way and actually
increase the imagination powers and the
adroitness of thinkers an example that
we started work on this and then for
various reasons had to abandon it but
it's still a dream of mine and it's the
we call it the tube which stands for
Tufts University brain Explorer but the
idea was that it would do for the brain
what the wonderful London Tube map does
for the underground color-coded
simplified straighten out the lines
throw away extra geographical
information that isn't really important
so you can see the connectivity and we
were going to have this lovely big
three-dimensional color coded system
that would permit students to see
what was fastened to what and why in the
brain and we would update it as we went
I still think that's a great idea
and like the to map the idea was you can
you can take the London to map and you
can then you can impose it on a map
which is geographically accurate and you
can discover things that you can't see
when you're looking at the map and it's
regularize simplified idealized form and
we want to do the same thing with the
brain when you when you look at the
thing in its idealized form the cortex
is all unfolded and it's this great dome
of a sheet with all this regular all the
columns and all the layers beautifully
laid out and you can see it looks like a
computer then you shrink wrap the whole
thing to fit in the skull and then you
can understand why certain things are
right next to each other in the brain
even though they're not connected so I
think that it's possible to use computer
technology to enhance our imaginations
not just bypass our imaginations and I'd
like to see more of that done yeah yep I
was just curious if you had the
opportunity right now to upload to the
rest of humanity one intuition pump and
only one which one would that be and why
Oh
the trouble is that they're for
different different people in some cases
the one that I would upload for
philosophers is one which I published in
Darwin's dangerous idea and because many
philosophers do that as you know then
it's popular book about Darwinism not
really a philosophy book they didn't
read it but there's that's the two black
boxes thought experiment which I think
just drives a spike through the heart of
an issue several issues that meta
physicians have been scratching their
heads about for
twenty-five years and we'll see maybe
second time around they'll pay attention
to it Thanks you think you can teach a
humorless person to have a sense of
humor
no probably not
in consciousness explained at one point
I sort of promised to come up with a
theory of humor and laughter and then I
couldn't and I sort of wished I could
erase that sentence because I couldn't
keep that promise and then in some few
years ago a student showed up Matthew
Hurley he wanted to do a theory of humor
with me and at first I thought his
theory was hopeless didn't like it at
all
but he gradually convinced me of it and
we did that book together with reg Adams
inside jokes using humor to
reverse-engineer the mind and I'm really
glad that I did that because I learned a
ton and I'm really proud of the theory
it's the Hurley model it's not mine in
the first place although I've tweaked it
a good deal but uh among other things
that explains is sort of why you can't
have an algorithm for being humorous
even though we argue it's the brain as a
computer and and we want it is a
computational it's an evolutionary
computational model of humor but it it's
not an algorithm for funny and we don't
think there is one and we say why the
one of the ways we did the research on
that is actually to spend some time not
only reading the worst but talking with
comedians and comedy writers to find out
sort of how they how they go about their
trade and how they use their own brains
as sounding boards and then their brains
get sort of distorted and it's they
can't clear their palate in effect they
can't they can't find the touch because
they've used it too much in certain ways
it's that's that among other reasons is
why I think humor it will always be sort
of an art not a not a science but that
doesn't mean there isn't the science of
why it's an art
somewhere here hi we run a
decision-making company we help teams
think through complex problems and I was
really struck by your comment that all
serious thinking is interpersonal which
will run counter to what we hear a lot
every day or the resistance we face I'm
just interesting to know what leads you
to that conclusion well many things do
one of them is a very recent paper in
behavioural brain sciences by Hugo
Mercier and dance / bear on the flaws in
our reasoning and they argue that as
part of our evolutionary heritage we're
better at detecting the flaws and an
opponent than in our own case where we
just are constitutionally bad at
gritting our teeth and looking for
errors in what we believe and our
reasons for it but we're very good at
ferreting out the errors in what the
other side believes well if that's true
and they make a good case for it then as
just about everywhere else in nature the
way to do this is with an opponent
process our eyes work with an opponent
process in several ways first of all the
muscles that determine where your eye
looks next those are sort of in a
constant tug-of-war with each other
pulling this way that but that's a very
sort of friendly tug-of-war but then in
the frontal eye fields we've got this
other opponent process going on
where there are little teams of neurons
that are saying about wherever fixation
is some of them are saying home sweet
home nice I like this familiar and the
others are saying boring been there done
that they want to move and this is
constant opponent process between
different groups
neurons transit look over here no look
where we're looking and and they they
Duke it out constantly all day long and
the result is that you have very good
patterns of eye tracking because in the
opponent processes among the little
groups they get the job done very well
unless you've got a problem and if
you've got a deficiency there then you
get abnormal saccadic and if you have
abnormal sick adding that means you're
not looking where you should be looking
when you should be looking and that is a
profound deficit there's strong evidence
for instance that autistic children do
not have normal saccadic they don't look
where they should they're not good at
gaze monitoring their mothers and and
they don't they're not good at at joint
attention and this means that whereas a
normal infant is just sucking from a
firehose of information all the time
some are not sort of attending to the
right place at the right time and it
changes the way their whole brain works
sometimes for the better sometimes for
the worst so I think opponent processes
our Nature's Way of getting jobs done
very often and we should just
acknowledge that and exploit it and
refine it for whatever it is what we're
trying to do I was fascinated where your
approach on freewill and I don't know
about anybody else here but remember
we're coming into into into touch with
the idea the kind of sexy rebellious
idea that the free will is an illusion
it seemed to gel with it I think what I
love
people were intuiting surely about kind
of non-religious heading towards a more
material explanation of things that's
very leftist to think anti free will but
you argue very powerfully Pro free will
and so I just wanted to find out what if
you could explain when
the neuroscience sources are that
explained materially where free will
occurs and when it occurred and also and
also if we want to debate whether it
exists or not where you want to see the
debate moving on you know there's a lot
of mm sociologists who want us to be
talking about freewill purely because
they want to they want to say that look
there's a certain class of people who
are populating our prisons politicians
mainly in this country but where yeah
where would you like to see that debate
go what's it's useful application and
and and yet in the neuroscience thank
you there's a lot in that but and I
appreciate all of it actually and I've
been thinking and talking a lot about
what prison reforms we might want to do
and what whether the system of
punishment needs any revision some of
you may have seen the review I did of
Adrian Raines wonderful book in Prospect
last month
Adrian reign is the neuroscientist
psychologist who's studied the brains of
psychopaths on death row
murderers a lot of them and even more
amazing as the experiments he did where
he got a lot of of psychopaths in the
wild that is they'd never been in any
trouble with the law well how do you how
do you find psychopaths in the wild he
had a hunch he got a grant he hired
dozens of temp workers in Los Angeles
and found that sure enough when he gave
them all the tests that are used in the
prisons for psychopathy so it's the sort
of gold standard measure the there were
psychopaths among the temps at a rate
about three times the the average in the
regular population so now we had a group
of psychopaths that had never been in
prison had any trouble of law and under
the certificate of confidentiality that
his work was done he was able to get his
graduate assistants to interview these
in depth
and they all confessed to armed
robberies rapes even murders so they
really are psychopaths and they're
really out there and and he's got the
tools to study them psychopaths are
different there but there's other people
with other sorts of brain differences
that we have to treat differently in our
in our system of law and punishment I
don't agree with all of reigns
proposals I don't think he does either
by the way but it's he's raised the
issue very well and it was called the
anatomy of violence but in my own work
what I want to do is turn the tables a
little bit and say instead of looking at
the metaphysical foundations of free
will and whether or not quantum
indeterminacy plays a role work
backwards start with the idea of the
free agent as being morally competent
being a morally competent agent and ask
yourself what are the specs for a
morally competent agent what does it
have to have in it what does it what
should you be able to do to be morally
competent and we can work that out I
think quite well and it turns out that
neuroscience has next to nothing to say
about about how normal people might not
be morally competent I think normal
people are morally competent and hence
in that sense have free will and because
they have free will they are proper and
because they're morally competent they
are appropriate bearers of full
responsibility for their deeds and this
includes their eligibility for
punishment when they commit misdeeds
that's a long story but I think that's a
constructive way of proceeding most of
us I daresay everybody in this room
believes they have free will in this
sense if you believe that you are
competent enough to sign a contract
binding contract then then you have
freewill in this sense I mean then you
believe you have freewill
in this sense has nothing to do with
determinism or in determinism it has to
do with your ability to assess outcomes
probabilities consequences costs and
benefits the value of reputation and so
forth if you've got all of that then
when you sign a contract you mean it and
so it counts anybody else yet one more
up top
yes let's go thank you for your
presentation I have a question with
regards to the connection between the
physical part of our brain how this is
impacted in our networked and
computerized communication as we move on
more and more into online networking and
communication and how this will impact
our history of philosophy going forward
so you know what would our thinking be
different let's say compared to the
Greeks and how this will be changing and
what we need to be thinking about oh I
think the answer is yes it's very clear
that our thinking today is different
from the ancient Greeks because as small
children we can master all sorts of
concepts but not the smartest people in
Athens couldn't master not just about
science but certainly about science I
think we have a hugely enlarged
conceptual repertory today compared with
the ancient Greeks that doesn't mean
that they weren't wise but I think it
does does mean that it was harder for
them to work these things out and if you
look at Plato's dialogues for instance
at least to my eyes often what I see
there strikes me as who
growing heroic attempts to think about
topics that Plato and his interlocutors
don't have the terms for and they're
sort of inventing distinctions in terms
as they go along and sometimes making
rather embarrassing mistakes by today's
standards I had the same impression when
I went back some years ago and read the
books that were my favorite books when I
was a graduate student in Oxford first
learning about the brain and trying to
think about the mind as the brain and
there wasn't very much that was written
it was good what was good was in its way
brilliant but they just didn't have the
tools they didn't have the thinking
tools the expression tools that we have
today and they labored brilliantly and
eccentrically and ingeniously to explain
things that now I think that the average
smart 14 year old could put quite aptly
in a few simple sentences of cyber
speech thanks I think that's a good
point on which to stop thank you
you